when I go for something and I go for it
at the expense of everything else I
always trust my gut that's all I have
everything is possible and nothing is
guaranteed hello bleep nation its Evan
my one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today we're
gonna learn from actor and producer Tom
Hiddleston and my take on his top ten
rules to success rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best also as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below I put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired by it as well and
if you leave it within the first couple
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
[Music]
I don't that I've ever been able to to
do anything III say it as a syllabus I'm
aware that it can be a strength but it
can also be a weakness because the focus
is obsessive and and so when I go for
something I go for it at the expense of
everything else and I I love what I do
simply and I I feel so lucky that I'm
allowed to do it and that I did get to
do it for a living and and cinema and
theatre have had such a profound effect
on me in my life it's you know it's just
a gut feeling I think I think I always
trust my gut that's all I have
even when I'm working and you're
thinking about the shape of a scene and
how it should be played and and your
head can often get in a way and you
gotta trust your gut and I it's just if
I'm inspired if my curiosity is piqued
and I want to chase this possibility
down that I see in front of me on my
desk you know it's um and some of you
may have heard me say this before but it
and I always I'm embarrassed to say I
always speak in metaphors I don't know
how to speak in any other way and and
for me acting is it's kind of like
playing the piano and and and if the
piano is the human condition and we all
have every single note on that 88 key
board within us and for me every role I
want to be able to play every note and
some and sometimes if a character or a
story seems to seem to stretch me in
some way seems to to offer up an
experience that is new that is a
different chord or a different tune
that I have that is that is that is real
and true and human and and accessible
and no matter how joyous or or loving or
warm or how dark or painful if it seems
like an interesting shape to an Abbott
I'm running I know if I'm running
towards it already okay a couple of
basic things beyond time never
underestimate the importance of
punctuality be prepared you can never be
over prepared and be true to yourself
and if you have something that you want
to say that you've been burning to say
don't ever let anyone tell you that you
can't say it everything is possible
and nothing is guaranteed and you start
auditioning and you if you're lucky
enough you have an agent and you start
auditioning and they send you everything
from period drama to casualty to Dairy
Milk commercials yep I went up for a
Dairy Milk commercial when I was little
and and you are thrown into the business
and thrown into it at the deep end and
there's no time for doubt or failure
they accept routinely that's what
happens to all of us and I was so I
perhaps was too careful in auditioning
and I would always get close to to
landing roles and to booking jobs and I
would never quite get there and it's
it's a I mean that this is a universal
experience for all created people
certainly actors is that the constant
rejection at the beginning and you had
to get used to it and you have to get
thick-skinned about it and I was so
exhausted by I was I trying to sort of
because at first you take it very
personally and I thought well no one's
like no one's gonna no one's gonna help
me get there the only person who can do
this is me and I started preparing in a
different way and and I sort of stepped
up to the plate a little better I think
because I could feel time sliding away
and and I wasn't getting on with life if
I just was sort of stuck in this rut of
neither acting nor doing anything else
and
the experience of being in your twenties
is so energetic and I felt so stagnant
actually so I just kind of changed
everything up and it worked I think a
myth in in in the in the businesses that
we all have we all have everything to
choose from is that we don't you know I
know I'm not like top of everybody's
list it's it's no but that's not it's
not I mean it just you have to earn that
place like Matt Damon always used to say
every script he got he knew it had Brad
Pitt's finger tips all over it and you
know mine just happened to be Michael
Fassbender that's okay no listen he's an
amazing he's an amazing actor really
truly gifted and that was kind of a joke
is it's it's it's a every actor is
completely different and but you know at
some times you might read something and
think I have read things and gone wow
this is amazing and I've chased it down
and knocked on the door and people have
said that it's not you Tom a week we're
thinking of someone different and then
my job is to keep knocking on the door
and say why you got it you know let me
see if I can change your mind I think
the most enjoyable thing about writing
for me is is when I sense that in
pushing myself and challenging myself to
explore new territory
I would submit when I'm 8 when you make
a connection with people when people
tell you that they've been moved by
something or that they related to
something it's but just it is it's about
connection and I find it really it stems
from my own my own passion as an
audience member as I remember I remember
my world being changed the way I saw the
world I remember being changed by films
by and by theatre the day that I saw One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest I woke up
and I couldn't stop thinking about it
for weeks and and I think cinema and
theatre and the same is true of
I told this story before but I went to
see a production of John Gabriel Balkman
at the National Theatre when I was 14
and it's the last time that Paul
Scofield was on stage and he was with
Vanessa Redgrave and Eileen Atkins and I
saw it was very conscious of an audience
of strangers arriving at the National
Theatre after a day of doing whatever
they were doing doing their job coming
from all quarters of the city to London
to this the home of the theatre on the
south bank having a drink catching up
rushing in taking their seats the lights
going down and three hours later the
entire theatre sobbing wiping away the
same tears in recognition of the same
grief which is universal and feeling
like Paul Scofield particularly had
spoken to my experience and I'd never
met him and I will always be grateful to
him for that and so I that's what I love
about it really is is that if as I say
that's that's um acting connects people
that's what I enjoy and so I always
every time a new script or a new role
comes along I am motivated by the
thought that I will I won't forgive
myself if I don't give it everything and
but I do try to choose different kinds
of things because I'm interested in in
the diversity of people and though and
the complexity of people and the
multiplicity we contain within us I
really think the thing that unites us
all in the world is that we are
constantly in constant and that
inconstancy in that contradiction is
something that I've always tried to
explore with my characters because I
think we do we do things that the
contrary contradicts ourselves all the
time there's a the Walt Whitman poem the
song of myself' I am large I contain
multitudes I contradict myself learning
learn learning is the legwork anyone
knew anyone wouldn't anyone knows who's
been in anything a play or a film like
that's that's what that's our job we
have to get these words into our
and it's I can't sit down I can't
literally I can't sit down and and and
read something and just learn it by rote
I have to be on the move so I tend to
dislike and the deranged guy in London
who's like walking around pretending
he's on the phone but actually like I'm
speaking in iambic pentameter cause I'm
learning Shakespeare and it's just it's
literally just repetition repetition
repetition you kind of drill it into
yourself it's like learning I always say
that you have to know the thing that
yours the the text as well as you know
happy birthday like if someone asks you
to sing it you know a jazzy version of
happy birthday you'd know because you
know that you know happy birthday goes
or if they asked you to do it like
Beethoven need to be able to do that and
it has to be in your body with as much
kind of confidence and as that so it's
just repetition really compassion is
about understanding compassion is
without ego if that's possible for
actors I don't know as an actor to have
compassion as an actor is to have
compassion for the characters that I
play that's what it means to me and and
whatever they're going through whatever
their predicaments and I have to suffer
with them I have to understand I have to
not judge it I have to be forgiving of
it now whether it's a circumstance or or
their true nature to have compassion for
another human being is or to have
compassion for a character is no
different from
having compassion from another human
being
that it was an event if Seoul in South
Korea and and I was I was there with the
fellowmen and we were there was a big
event and there were 7,000 people there
in a a big shopping centre called Time
Square and I was taking some questions
on stage and somebody asked in what body
part are you most confident in which I
thought was a a new question and 111
hadn't been asked before and so I
thought the most innocuous answer was to
say my feet because without my feet I
couldn't run and I loved running and was
and also I couldn't dance and I love
dancing so then they said well now we
have to see you dance so I thought I got
a walk right into this but it was fun
you know someone tell me about it I was
like what's he done he's a really good
dancer
it's incredible I heard does that
rehearsed that was not an improvised
dance that one yeah check it out I'd
like to see that he's amazing he's
really got it he's really got it he's
adorable
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because telling it like
it is mm asked me to if there's someone
you like me to profile in their future
top ten please check out the link down
in the description below and you can
cast your vote on who we should do next
I also want to give a quick shout a to
Tori Tori thank you so much for picking
up one of my t-shirts the rebel t-shirt
it looks great on you and I hope you're
enjoying wearing it out thank you for
sharing the picture on instagram for me
and to your audience as well I really
appreciate the support thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we can't you need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
don't miss this just workout here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]